Crackdown measures will be announced by
Rishi sunak on Monday says Rishi sunak
and the main proposal is indeed for a
mandatory Duty for professionals to
report their suspicions looking the
other way that's the charge against some
of those professionals she names
politicians social workers teachers
police officers and others saying that
they're more concerned of political
correctness and afraid of being accused
of racism
John thank you and the Home Secretary
Sola bravman will be speaking to Sophie
Ridge tomorrow morning at half past
eight
three British men are being held in
Taliban custody in Afghanistan including
so-called danger tourist miles Rutledge
who returned to the country after being
evacuated by British armed forces less
than two years ago the other two men are
charity medic Kevin Cornwell and another
unnamed UK National who manages a hotel
in Kabul they're all believed to have
been held by taliban's secret police
since January in separate incidents as
Skies Lisa Holland reports
when the Taliban retook control in
Afghanistan it was an extraordinary
sight an extraordinary moment after 20
years out of power
but whilst tens of thousands tried to
flee along with departing International
forces self-styled danger tourist miles
Routledge wanted to see for himself and
went in he was evacuated but returned
and it's emerged he's one of the three
britons being held by the Taliban the 23
year old has previously boasted to his
online followers that he travels to the
most dangerous places on Earth for fun
it's not known what led to his arrest
there's no connection between him and
the two other britons being held charity
medic Kevin Cornwall 53 and another
British national who hasn't been named
who manages a hotel for Aid workers in
the capital Kabul
[Music]
an organization in touch with the
families of Kevin Cornwell and the
unnamed British national say Mr Cornwell
was arrested in a raid at his hotel and
accused of having an illegal firearm we
believe our critical basis is that the
GDI which is the Taliban intelligence
reacted to a tip regarding our weapons
stored in the in the premises uh that
weapon was licensed and we believe that
during the course of the search that the
license may have been separated from the
weapon and this circumstances ultimately
the extension of a misunderstanding we
do believe they are in good health and
being well treated we have no reason to
believe they've been subject to sort of
um any any negative treatment such as
torture and we're told that they are
they're as good as can be expected in
such circumstances
the UK does not have an embassy or any
consulates in Afghanistan following the
Taliban Takeover in a statement the
foreign Commonwealth and development
office said we are working hard to
secure Consular contact with British
Nationals detained in Afghanistan and
who are supporting families
negotiations will be difficult but
Security Experts say the Taliban May
demand some kind of prisoner swap in
return for the britons they're holding
Lisa Holland Sky News